les jeux de société sont ils le loisir
de sept années 2020 ils ont eu beaucoup
de succès durant le confinement nous
sommes partis voir c'était vraiment le
cas
vous avez joué beaucoup j'ai tous
étaient cette année
ac oui pendant le confinement on en a
pas mal profité avec les enfants on a
quoi comme jeu
on a même le match thurman la bouteille
le monopoly tout de même des villes à
cette année cette année oui pour en
essayer d'autres comme fort boyard qui
d'ailleurs est un excellent jeu ans pour
passer le temps en famille parce qu'il y
avait des jeux afin d'aider me mener des
tests à faire donc c'est sympa
vous le voyez beaucoup on joue aux jeux
de société je me rendais à présent dans
une boutique spécialisée pour parler des
succédanés
[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes avec le créca des
gens vous êtes responsable de la
boutique tofo police où ils nous
donnaient les tendances de cette année
2020 cette année 2010 est une année
particulière donc une année particulière
où il a fallu qu'on joue à distance et
tout ça et donc il ya des jeux qui ont
vraiment exploser ça va être tout ce qui
est les relais devra établir des jeux on
peut partager un écran vous permettre de
jouer ensemble même si on n'est pas à
côté il ya aussi la consolidation de
tous les jeux de skate jam dont une
loque était un des précurseurs alors
tous ces jeux où on essaye de rendre de
résoudre une énigme ensemble et puis il
ya aussi tout ce qu'on appelle les jeux
coopératifs il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
jeux coopératifs pour émerger cette
année voilà un peu les tendances de la
mairie merci beaucoup
christophe déjean et nous allons nous
rendre maintenant j'ai d'un éditeur de
jeux de société implantée dans les
yvelines
[Musique]
hélène barral bonjour bonjour vous êtes
donc fondatrice et pdg d'exode game donc
c'est une maison d'édition qui a été
fondée en 2017 et qui est basé à
guyancourt
donc vous avez multiplié par 3 votre
chiffre d'affaires depuis la création
alors là c'est une année un peu
particulière celle année-là nicoli on
l'appelle comme ça et ça n'a pas été
facile mais bon et on est toujours là on
s'accroche vous avez quand même vendu
beaucoup de jeux de société cette année
puisque avec le confinement on suppose
que les gens ont alors juste jouer
premier confinement en mars des gobies
nahd a subi sa toute première rupture il
sans ambages sa toute première rupture
depuis sa création donc c'était première
fois que les boutiques m'a appelé en
urgence pour en avoir et il est en train
de subir sa deuxième culture
donc voilà il repart en production
également donc c'était une bonne
nouvelle pour le jeu mais que oui les
ventes ont été on était là par contre
votre chiffre d'affaires s'en est plutôt
bien sorti cette année
comme toujours avec stratégico vite ça
prend quand même aimé les jeux de
société ont été un peu moins impactées à
ce que beaucoup de gens veulent jouer
pendant les confinements merci beaucoup
ellaone si elle veut vous l'aurez
compris les jeux de société sont donc
bien le loisir de sept années 2020 moi
je vais aller faire une petite partie
des jurassique world